i hear you killing people again
what new documentary everyone's talking
about it tells full of asbestos you've
been putting asbestos in our makeup the
whole time do all the chemists and
toxicologists making the products no
don't know they weren't in the
documentary
huh that's weird
they seem like the obvious people to ask
what experts did they use
lawyers talking about science were they
at least unbiased lawyers they're
representing the people suing over talc
oh come on it's really convincing they
show the girl who exposed claire's
crying and everything wait wasn't that
like five years ago so were they already
filming then or did they purposely make
her cry so they could film it because
that's kind of a lot i don't know but
i'm convinced
unless you do a video about it
it's michelle of labma from beauty
science chemistry phd cosmetic chemist
and person who
like pretty much everyone i think is
concerned about her health but not so
into people trying to exploit this
concern for attention or for profit hbo
have a new 4-part documentary not so
pretty and it's about supposedly
dangerous beauty products this kind of
documentary comes out every six months
or so and everyone panics and throws out
their products i've watched it with some
of my cosmetic chemist friends who are
all really knowledgeable you should go
follow them all today i'm going to be
breaking down episode one like and
subscribe if you like talking about the
science behind beauty products episode
one is called makeup and it's mostly
about asbestos in talc talc is a powdery
ingredient that's commonly found in
makeup and baby powder and there's some
controversy about how talc can sometimes
be contaminated with asbestos asbestos
is a spiky mineral that's linked to some
forms of cancer they discussed what
happened with claire's makeup which was
found to contain asbestos in 2017 and
johnson and johnson baby powder which is
the subject of a whole bunch of lawsuits
from plaintiffs claiming that it caused
their cancer mostly ovarian cancer but
also mesothelioma a cancer that's
closely linked to asbestos exposure
before we go any further i need to
remind everyone documentaries aren't
science in science we try to conduct
fair tests then we look at all the data
to work out what it tells us if the
studies disagree you have to work out
which studies are flukes which ones
weren't fair which ones aren't relevant
and which ones were just plain wrong if
there isn't a conclusive answer you have
to work out how much certainty there is
and what the sensible thing is to do in
the meantime documentaries don't have to
play by these rules they need to tell a
good story and this story is chosen by
the filmmakers who generally aren't
experts in the topic because they're
experts in making films you would hope
that the documentary makers would
consult relevant experts and base their
documentary on what the science says
but
there's no obligation to do that you
would also hope that they would try to
be transparent that they would say if
the relevant experts that they
approached disagreed with what they said
foreshadowing but again there's no real
rules they can choose to only show the
bits of evidence that fit the narrative
they already had in mind and this is
commonly called cherry picking it's like
only showing footage of snow to make it
seem like global warming isn't happening
and unfortunately science is complex it
usually doesn't make as good a story as
a sensational black and white
cherry-picked narrative that plays on
fears and misconceptions that we the
audience already have and if i watched
not so pretty without already knowing a
lot of the background
i probably would have been quite
convinced this is a really slickly made
series that does actually bring up some
good points
but then it mixes them in with a lot of
really bad points and they support it
with very unobjectively selected
evidence and questionable leaps of logic
so the first episode makeup the main
theme is the idea that products with
chalk contain asbestos and therefore
they have a high chance of causing harm
to consumers they're mostly talking
about powder makeup like eye shadow and
face powder and talcum powder the
episode focuses on a 26 year old woman
corinne who was diagnosed with
mesothelioma a type of cancer that's
usually caused by asbestos after corinne
was diagnosed with mesothelioma she
decided to have the makeup products she
owned that contained talc tested
10 of her 25 makeup products contained
asbestos the cases involving christie
and corrine clearly points to a concern
with many other talc products
so the documentary makes the case that
asbestos in korean's makeup caused the
mesothelioma and that her story is
representative of the dangers to
consumers from talc in makeup they also
talk about how christy found asbestos in
claire's makeup in 2017 which was a huge
story at the time and this leads to the
conclusion and it's not going to stop
unless talc products are no longer being
used
to me there are a lot of issues with
this whole line of reasoning the first
issue this documentary never mentions
that there's a lot more data on asbestos
and child products other than this one
woman's makeup collection
and what happened with this one brand
the reason that asbestos in claire's
makeup was such a big story was that it
was really shocking it's rare and
unexpected and quite glaringly the
documentary doesn't talk about how this
claire's incident actually spurred the
fda to start investigating asbestos and
talc in cosmetics there is a section of
the fda website that is entirely
dedicated to talc this is
a pretty huge thing for them not to
mention to the point where it feels like
maybe they deliberately left it out
because this episode does talk a lot
about how the fda doesn't do enough but
for this specific issue with talc and
asbestos the fda have actually done
something they've been updating methods
for detecting asbestos and looking for
asbestos in talc containing products
they did two surveys in 2019 and 2021
and they used the more sensitive
techniques that the geologists in the
documentary mentioned i find it hard to
believe that the filmmakers could have
missed this it comes up immediately if
you google talc fda in the 2019 fda
survey 52 products from 23 brands were
tested asbestos was found in nine
products from three brands three out of
five products from claire's five out of
seven products from city color and one
out of two baby powders from johnson and
johnson in the 2021 survey they tested
50 products from 33 brands and no
asbestos was detected in any of them
these numbers are most likely higher
than what's on the market because the
fda prioritized testing brands and
products that they suspected had
asbestos so in total that's three brands
out of 53 that had tau containing
products with asbestos
and nine products out of the 102 tested
that had asbestos on the other hand 10
out of 25 of karin's products had
asbestos this is close to half so it
doesn't seem to be representative of tau
containing cosmetic products on the
market overall there's also the fact
that people who use more makeup
don't seem to be noticeably more prone
to mesothelioma mesothelioma is linked
to asbestos exposure
but it's usually prolonged heavy
exposure such as in people who work in
industries where there's a lot of
asbestos and even then most asbestos
workers don't get mesothelioma asbestos
is a trace contaminant in cosmetic talc
and as the fda surveys showed it isn't
often in there when it is it's in really
tiny amounts on the other hand before
the mid-1980s
huge amounts of asbestos were used in
construction since it's a good insulator
and it's fireproof it was used in wall
insulation pipe insulation roof shingles
textured ceilings and walls
two-thirds of houses built between the
1930s and 1980s in australia contain
asbestos as do more than half of u.s
homes it generally isn't a big problem
unless you're renovating your house or
the panels containing asbestos are
falling apart because they're getting
old or because of a natural disaster
when this happens the spiky asbestos
particles can be released into the air
and you can breathe it in which is the
main route of exposure that leads to
mesothelioma there's also asbestos in
old brake pads and as they wear down and
get used the asbestos fibers go into the
air so typically the people who get
mesothelioma are blue collar workers who
work closely with lots of asbestos as
part of their job there are also higher
rates in people who live near asbestos
mines and factories and people who live
with asbestos workers since they can
bring home asbestos dust on their
clothes on top of that asbestos in the
air is higher in a lot of cities because
of breaks four times as many men are
diagnosed with mesothelioma than women
and most of these men are over 65 which
overwhelmingly points towards working
with large amounts of asbestos being the
biggest issue in the us there are about
3 000 diagnoses per year so it's a
relatively rare cancer there's no known
increased risk for makeup artists or
models or people who manufacture
cosmetics or mothers with many children
which you would expect if using makeup
or baby powder was a big risk factor and
the amounts of asbestos in makeup and
baby powder are so small to begin with
compared to how much is in a lot of
homes for example this doesn't mean that
asbestos in makeup and baby powder will
never cause even a single case of
mesothelioma you can be really unlucky a
tiny asbestos fiber could just happen to
land in the exact wrong place to cause
health problems but
more exposure to asbestos means there's
a higher chance of this happening and it
seems like a pretty big distortion of
the actual risk to spend 35 minutes
talking about tiny amounts of asbestos
in a small number of makeup and baby
powder products
and warning people to avoid all products
with talc without ever mentioning how
you should be careful about drilling
into walls and older houses or cracked
ceiling panels or getting an asbestos
evaluation of your house before you
renovate these things could reduce your
exposure to a lot more asbestos and
they're recommended on official health
websites whereas makeup and baby powder
aren't mentioned and one possibility
that steven raised in our live viewing
is that maybe it would be worth
investigating if corinne has an asbestos
problem in her house probability wise
it's a much more likely explanation for
why a young woman might develop
mesothelioma than using makeup it would
also explain why her makeup products are
so much more contaminated than the
products on the market maybe they did
investigate it but it isn't mentioned
whether or not that is the underlying
reason her experience isn't
representative of the overall safety of
talc containing products in the us
anecdotes like these are really
persuasive we can see these people we
can relate to them we can get
emotionally invested in their stories
but it's still just one example that may
or may not tell us about the overall
picture and the real things we should be
focusing on the choice of experts that
not so pretty used in this episode also
seems to point to cherry picking in this
episode they only feature one relevant
scientist a geologist who analyzes talc
samples for asbestos almost all of the
explanations that we get about the
science of asbestos and talc and their
health risks are from true lawyers both
represent plaintiffs in tel cases
as well as a journalist so it's an
extremely one-sided view that's being
presented we are basically just hearing
one side of a court case you would maybe
expect some input from relevant
qualified scientists like cosmetic
chemists or toxicologists who work in
cosmetic safety or asbestos so why don't
they appear in this
well it turns out that some cosmetic
chemists were actually approached by the
filmmakers perry and valerie of the
beauty brains podcast but their
perspective didn't match what the
documentary makers seemed to already
have in mind and i'm sure they couldn't
have been the only relevant experts that
were approached and left out it's also a
bit questionable how this episode is
called makeup it starts and ends talking
about makeup but most of the middle is
actually spent talking about baby powder
i think this is because there is a
stronger case against baby powder
there's a lot more talc in baby powder
than in makeup to begin with and most of
the lawsuits on talc are against johnson
and johnson so why did this episode
focus so much on makeup rather than baby
powder and try to like mash the two
together i would guess it's because j
and j stopped selling chalk baby powder
in the u.s in 2020 so a baby powder
episode wouldn't be as
attention-grabbing this thing you
probably can't buy anymore could be
dangerous is just not going to be as
viral as the stuff you use every day is
killing you as jen mentioned in our
viewing it's also worth noting that most
of the lawsuits were actually about
talcum powder causing ovarian cancer not
mesothelioma again this seems to be a
deliberate choice a paper looking at the
data from over a quarter million people
was published in 2020 and it found that
there was no significant increase in the
risk of ovarian cancer for people who
use powder in their genital area
importantly the authors weren't involved
in any talcum powder lawsuits which is
very rare for newer publications about
talc so it seems like the documentary
makers might have purposely gone for a
smaller issue that's a bit harder to
debunk because the bigger issues fallen
through all the episodes of not so
pretty also bring up real complex
important issues involving inequality
race access to healthcare workplace
protections and social justice but a lot
of the time they imply that we can solve
these issues just by changing the
ingredients in your beauty products for
this episode they say consumers can act
by avoiding all talc products which as
we talked about earlier isn't a
recognized risk factor they don't
mention any of the other better
recognized preventative things you could
do that medical organizations actually
recommend they also recommend using apps
like skin deep detox me and cleria which
rate and rank product safety and lists
dangerous ingredients
so it's really pushing clean beauty apps
and clean beauty logic where ingredients
can be neatly divided into good and bad
and you can work out how safe a product
is based on just the ingredients list
i've talked about this before it is a
really clever marketing technique but
it's just not the way the world works
how safe an ingredient is depends on how
you're exposed to it this is a very
basic principle in toxicology the most
important factor is usually how much
there is a concept that's commonly
referred to as the dose makes the poison
the ingredients list usually doesn't
have many numbers clean beauty apps and
websites also often misinterpret studies
they'll take studies on cells and
animals where they might have fed the
ingredient to rats or injected it into
them
and they just assume that they have the
same health effects in humans and the
thing is proper trained toxicologists
have actually analyzed the same studies
before and published their conclusions
and cosmetic chemists use ingredients
and products based on their
recommendations so on one side you have
scientists with years and years of
specialized knowledge saying that these
ingredients are safe when used in
certain ways you also have formulators
who know where they got their
ingredients from they know the
impurities in them they know how much
they put into the product and they know
these safe recommendations and then on
the other side you have these clean
beauty organizations that don't know how
much is in the product or where the
ingredient comes from saying that it is
just blanket unsafe plus these
organizations seem not to know that
humans aren't cells in a petri dish or
rats and really just the basics of
toxicology the two sides are just really
not equal and then to recommend clean
beauty as the solution to these complex
social problems
it makes me really frustrated because
these issues really need to be solved
and the world research solutions are
complex and a lot of people are working
on them but not so pretty are really
emphasizing these oversimplified fake
solutions that aren't supported by the
evidence so they won't solve these
issues they could just act as a
distraction and make things worse they
also make consumers waste a whole bunch
of money by throwing out perfectly good
products and buying even more and a lot
of the ways this episode brings up these
issues in the first place
just don't really make sense for example
one of the lawyers said that jnj's baby
powder marketing targeted
african-american women that were
overweight that lived in the south
which is made up by the documentary to
be kind of sinister and predatory and
that according to lawsuits it has
something to do with the fact that this
demographic would be less likely to get
an early diagnosis and again inequality
of access to healthcare due to race and
other socio-economic factors is a really
big problem but demographic based
marketing is standard people from
different cultural backgrounds use
different products and one of the big
uses of baby powder is for reducing
shaving between the thighs in hot and
sweaty weather
so it seems like there's a much more
straightforward explanation that doesn't
involve a huge evil conspiracy the
documentary also says that j and j they
are still making a product in south
africa
in colombia and in india so they're
really targeting women of color
with
a product that could be carcinogenic but
j j's talc baby powder is also still
sold in a whole bunch of very white
european countries like ireland
switzerland germany and norway which
goes against this whole targeting women
of color theory so the good points i
think this episode made i completely
agree with this bit there is really no
government authority that is checking to
see whether the products are actually
safe i think a lot of us have seen posts
on social media about products with mold
product textures changing in concerning
ways products with dishonest advertising
like filters and illegal drug claims
some of us have even submitted
complaints to regulators and realized
that
very few of these get dealt with in any
official sort of way this isn't just a
problem in the us it's a problem pretty
much everywhere and the fda does
actually do more than a lot of other
countries the eu system tends to get
recommended by a lot of clean beauty
advocates
but on this specific issue their
regulators haven't actually publicly
investigated asbestos or published any
surveillance testing like the fda
studies i think it's a pretty crap
situation that a regular consumer had to
test the claire's makeup it just seems
like the sort of issue that regulators
should be more proactive in tackling i
also agree that the texas two-step
scheme that j and j are using sounds
pretty crappy it's a legal loophole that
allows companies to massively reduce
payouts in lawsuits and it seems
unsurprising that companies are going to
try to reduce their losses as much as
they legally can
hopefully legislation will close this
loophole so my takeaways first off
asbestos doesn't seem to be a common
issue in cosmetics according to better
evidence that the documentary seemed to
purposely ignore if you're still
uncomfortable using talc maybe avoid
using talcum powder this is one of the
bigger sources of talc and cornstarch
based alternatives work pretty well the
amount of talc and makeup that you
breathe in is pretty small to begin with
and based on those fda surveys asbestos
in makeup doesn't seem to be a big issue
more importantly if you're worried about
asbestos be aware of the bigger risks
like your home and any other buildings
you regularly go to i've left some
linked to medical websites in the
description when watching documentaries
be really alert about the ways that they
might be manipulating you some things
are hard to spot unless you already know
the topic but in a lot of documentaries
one obvious red flag is which experts
they use so ask yourself what experts
are they using are they the right
experts for the topic they're discussing
are there obvious categories of experts
missing if so look up what these experts
are saying i'll be talking about the
other episodes soon so subscribe and
click the notification bell for that
also hit the like and leave a comment if
you enjoyed this breakdown the full
convo from our watch party is a podcast
on the eco world there's also a great
book called getting risk right which i
really recommend if you want to get your
head around how to not get on that panic
wagon when these sorts of issues come up